die lage ist natürlich nach wie vor
angespannt da wir noch nicht
100-prozentig entwarnung geben können
zum einen weil das traditionell jahr
nach solchen anschlägen immer wieder
auch zu nachahmungstätern kommt und auf
der anderen seite deshalb weil noch
nicht hundertprozentig ausgeschlossen
werden konnte dass es nicht mehrere
täter gegeben hat wir gehen mittlerweile
davon aus dass es nur einen täter
gegeben hat der sich sehr schnell bewegt
hat und dann sechs orten in der wiener
innenstadt um sich geschossen hat und
eben zahlreiche menschen hier kaltblütig
ermordet hat aber wir haben noch keine
hundertprozentige gewissheit ist haben
mittlerweile sehr viele
hausdurchsuchungen stattgefunden im
umfeld des täters wir konnten 14
personen verhaften und versuchen jetzt
natürlich festzustellen ob es hier
beitragstäter gegeben hat ob es hier
personen gegeben hat die die tat mit
unterstützt haben mit vorbereitet haben
und ob der täter bei der tat selbst an
alleine war oder auch andere involviert
waren
fest steht dass es ein anschlag ein
terroranschlag war ein islamistischer
terroranschlag der täter bekennt sich
zum islamischen staat
und insofern war es ein anschlag auf
unsere freie demokratie auf unsere
lebensweise auf die gesamte gesellschaft
in österreich sie haben gesagt in einer
ansprache wir werden die täter jagen wie
läuft jetzt diese jagd ab und was wissen
sie über den täter zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt
wir wissen über den täter dass ein
österreicher ist mit einer
doppelstaatsbürgerschaft
österreichischen ort mazedonisch der
migrationshintergrund aus nord
mazedonien hat der auch schon einmal
verhaftet war und auch im gefängnis war
weil er sich dem islamischen staat
anschließen wollte und der jetzt sehr
stark bewaffnet mit einer machete einer
faustfeuerwaffe und auch einer
kalaschnikow diese tat begangen hat
es konnten mehrere personen aus dem
umfeld des täters verhaftet werden
und jetzt wird gerade festgestellt
welche personen in bei dieser tat
unterstützt haben
ob es hier verbindungen nach frankreich
oder anderswo hin ins ausland gibt da
wird der hintergrund der ist eindeutig
nämlich ein islamistischer
terroranschlag
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren